Hello everyone, My name is Dale Yoo and I work as CEO and creator of games at Daeri Soft.
We were developing easy games
Such as simplified games or puzzle games since 2008.
At present, our main game is Freestyle Baseball 2.
I gained the impetus to enter the gaming industry through my experience as a game graphics designer.
Everyone dreams of creating their own game.
So I entered strongly in the design of games using the retirement bonus.
Free style Baseball 1 brings together multiple players from around the world in real time.
I discovered that the real-time multiplayer functionality of the Google Play Games service allows
Both server functionality and player games with global users.
And gained very good experience while using these services.
It is clear that the real-time retention of players and players is closely related.
Our game was released in September and featured in the World Games section.
The game was offered for sale in about 140 countries.
Our game was downloaded 130,000 times a day
And one million times a month.
The figures were as follows.
15% in America,
And 10% in Korea,
And 10% in Japan
And 8% in Taiwan.
In terms of retention figures we got about 45% per day
For Korea, Japan and Taiwan.
In the case of America, the figure ranges from 35% to 40% per day.
We also received a lot of help when we did the pre-test.
At first, we tried a symbol,
Downloads increased by 10 to 15%.
As I mentioned earlier, the ratio increased by 10% when we moved on to steps 2 and 3.
When we took the last step, the percentage increased significantly by 200 to 300%.
This has led to our very positive situation,
Because the total number of downloads exceeded 130 thousand each day for global markets.
We have a plan to take advantage of Google's real-time API functionality
Players around the world can easily enjoy the game of Freestyle Sport World from Daeri Soft.
We will do our best to become a global company in the development of sports games.